The Russo Brothers have struck again.
The filmmaking pair have previously admitted
to including scenes in the trailers of their
Marvel films that are misleading or downright
absent from the finished product, and it turns
out Avengers: Endgame was no different.
Let's break the deception down.
Spoilers ahead!
First, consider this shot of Thor glancing
meaningfully at Stormbreaker.
This is quite obviously a massive red herring;
not only did the shot appear nowhere in the
film, but Thor looks nothing like this for
the majority of Endgame.
After the film's five-year time jump early
on, we see that the God of Thunder has been
drowning his sorrows in the recently-established
New Asgard.
The trailer's fakeout is almost certainly
a take from the Infinity War shoot, most likely
meant to make us believe that the Avengers
would have to revisit the Battle of Wakanda
and give Thor one more shot at going for the
head.
"You should've gone for the head."
Speaking of that time jump, some of the more
misleading moments from the trailers seem
to be designed to throw us off the scent of
that particular plot point.
For example, Black Widow is seen with her
Infinity War-style blonde locks when Scott
Lang arrives at the Avengers compound in the
trailer — but in the movie, this takes place
after the jump, and Natasha's hair has mostly
gone back to its natural red shade.
The shot of Natasha getting down with a little
target practice was omitted from the film
altogether, as was a shot of her sitting outside
in the rain in Japan while on the trail of
Clint Barton.
Another seemingly random alteration: the exchange
between Tony Stark and Steve Rogers before
the pair jump back to 1970 to retrieve the
Tesseract and more Pym Particles.
While the dialogue exchange in the trailer
is the same as the scene in the film, the
handshake appears to have simply been added
to promo spots for dramatic effect and to
let us know that, yes, the two Avengers have
finally mended fences.
A more significant difference here is Cap's
uniform; while in the trailers it's the updated
version from Infinity War, in the movie it's
his Avengers-era original outfit.
It's pretty easy to see why this was done
— Cap was sporting his old duds in order
to blend in during the time-traveling excursion
to the Battle of New York.
A few other shots seemingly ended up on the
cutting room floor for no reason in particular,
except perhaps to shave a few minutes off
Endgame's mammoth run time.
These include Bruce Banner agonizing over
the display showing all of the "missing and
presumed dusted" heroes, Clint and Natasha
sharing a private moment, and a poignant shot
of Tony Stark's face as he uses his trashed
Iron Man helmet to record a message to Pepper
Potts while adrift in space.
One other curious exclusion: Captain Marvel's
helmet, which she was seen wearing in the
trailer, but not during her triumphant return
during Endgame's climactic battle.
There's only one reason we can think of for
this: to hide Carol Danvers' new haircut,
which she sports after the time jump.
Finally, there's another, much more significant
change having to do with another Captain:
Steve Rogers, who is seen in both the trailer
and the film cinching up the straps on his
shield, a look of grim determination on his
face, as all hell appears to be breaking loose
around him.
The spot's version of the sequence is identical
to the one in the movie, save for one crucial
detail: Cap's shield is whole and unbroken.
In the film, it's been busted nearly in half
after a severe pummeling by Thanos, making
Rogers' action all the more badass as he prepares
to charge the Mad Titan with his trusty weapon
shattered beyond repair.
You've gotta hand it to the Russos: they're
dead serious about delivering exciting trailers
while preserving some of their biggest secrets,
as we saw when the trailers for Infinity War
led us to believe that a fully Hulked-out
Banner would be present at the Battle of Wakanda,
when he in fact was forced to suit up in Stark's
Hulkbuster armor due to the not-so-jolly Green
Giant refusing to come out to play.
Indeed, we're going to go ahead and say that
their trailer trickery is appreciated, as
Endgame's spots held back details that we
frankly wouldn't have wanted spoiled for us.
When you're fielding one of the biggest event
films in history, sometimes you've got to
give the audience what they don't know they
want, like a heaping helping of deception.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.